multitudes de personas en todo pakistán
están tratando de obtener los pagos de
socorro después de que bloques de casas
fueran destruidas por las devastadoras
inundaciones
fui al banco pero me dijeron que los
pagos no estaban listos así que vinimos
aquí y también nos dijeron que los
fondos no han llegado las inundaciones
las peores vistas en el país en décadas
están empeorando una crisis económica ya
catastrófica y el ministerio de
planificación de pakistán estima que las
pérdidas económicas iniciales por el
desastre climático podrían alcanzar al
menos 10 mil millones de dólares los
aguaceros sin precedentes han arrasado
carreteras cultivos e infraestructuras
dejando un tercio del país bajo el agua
según la ministra de clima se riman
literalmente un tercio de pakistán está
bajo el agua ahora mismo lo que ha
superado todos los límites todas las
normas que hemos visto en el pasado
incluso las super inundaciones de 2010
que arrasaron literalmente la mitad del
país fueron mejores que esto quiero
decir que hoy estamos mucho peor que en
de andy pettitte en mientras las
organizaciones benéficas reparten
alimentos a los residentes evacuados los
de la segunda ciudad más grande de
pakistán se preocupan por el aumento de
los precios de los alimentos ya que las
inundaciones de bastan millones de
hectáreas de tierra de cultivo los
precios han aumentado tanto a causa de
las inundaciones que muchos clientes se
van sin comprar nada después de
presentar el precio porque no pueden
pagarlo antes podríamos comprar un kilo
pero ahora ni siquiera podemos comprar
200 gramos así de caras están las cosas
nuestros ingresos no son suficientes
comparados con lo caras que están las
cosas mientras aparecen campamentos
improvisados por todo pakistán para dar
refugio a los desplazados el fondo
monetario internacional acordó liberar
más de 1100 millones de dólares a la
economía con problemas de liquidez como
parte de su programa de rescate